hobo royaume d'art endel a paru une
reine au pouvoir secret si puissant
qu'elle vécut dans la solitude et la
peine duquenne garde tout sang-froid
mais la force longtemps caché un jour
fut libéré
la sorcellerie et sous une neige
éternelle
le pays tout entier resta figé tout est
joué je vous en prie ne l'approchez pas
je la retrouverai tout s'arrangera vous
n'avez pas peur elle ne me fera pas de
mal c'est ma soeur c'est vrai je suis
persuadé que c'est un être exclue
bonjour c'est quoi ce monstre de la tête
bonjour à tous je m'appelle olaf s'il
est l'oeuvre des trains oui pourquoi il
faut mettre fin c'est super terrible
voilà il n'ambitionne pas sorti c'est
monstrueux de défaire un bonhomme et
vous vos cheveux deviennent blancs c'est
pas beau c'est ça non vous avez hésité
non pas du tout les doux
je pense au blizzard
c'est ma soeur
si nous faisons bien folichon touche
mort de froid
deffins à cet hiver s'il vous plaît mais
regardez je ne peux pas